Speaker 1: The news that Noam Chomsky hung out
with the late Jeffrey Epstein has really sent
many people for quite a loop. Chomsky was asked
about this and said, None of your business when
The Wall Street Journal inquired about it,
which is striking. At least some people in
my audience has a very strange response. It's
the entire thing is not incredibly newsworthy.
But I think what is setting some people
off is what they perceive to be a really
like the worst possible response from Noam
Chomsky. Now, of course, Jeffrey Epstein,
who is now deceased, now understood to be an
extraordinary predator involving young girls. And,
you know, all the the details are so beyond the
scope of what I can sort of illuminate here. But
this has been an ongoing story for a very, very
long time. And he is an extraordinarily horrifying
predator. And so every time it turns out someone
met with him, this happened to Bill Gates,
Trump and Clinton knew Epstein. It always sort
of generates a little bit of a story. But Alan
Dershowitz is another one who visited Jeffrey
Epstein's private island. I believe it was.
But Chomsky is surprising some. So there's a
Business Insider story. Renowned academic Noam
Chomsky told The Wall Street Journal that his
meetings with Jeffrey Epstein are, quote, None
of your business. None of your business. The Wall
Street Journal reports that Chomsky held multiple
meetings with Jeffrey Epstein. Chomsky's meetings
with Epstein took place long after the disgraced
financier had registered as a sex offender. So
the idea of this was long before anybody knew
anything. Not valid. It was. It was known when
the Journal asked Chomsky about the meetings, the
linguist had some choice words and the article.
It's a short article. Let's look at it because
it's interestingly written. When asked about their
connections with Jeffrey Epstein, many business
leaders and bureaucrats offered tight lipped
regrets and apologies. Not Noam Chomsky. The Wall
Street Journal, in an exclusive published Sunday,
said it obtained Epstein's private calendar. It
outlined numerous meetings with high profile
people, including Chomsky, the famed academic
and political activist. When the Journal reached
out to Chomsky, he had choice words. Quote,
First response is that it is none of your business
or anyone's. Second is that I knew him and we met
occasionally. Chomsky, 94, told the Journal in an
email. Epstein, the disgraced financier accused of
sex trafficking underage girls, died by suicide
in 2019 in a manhattan jail as he awaited trial.
In addition to Chomsky, the Journal noted meetings
with a current CIA director, William Burns,
as well as Katherine Rambler, a top lawyer at
Goldman Sachs and former White House counsel under
Obama. Epstein's meetings with Chomsky appear to
have taken place in 2015 and 16. Epstein was first
charged with procuring minors for prostitution and
registered as a sex offender in 2008. In March of
2015, Epstein scheduled meeting with Chomsky and
a Harvard University professor. Chomsky confirmed
that there were several meetings where they
discussed various topics. The Journal reported
that months later, Epstein scheduled a flight with
Chomsky and his wife for a planned dinner with
movie director Woody Allen and his wife, Soon-Yi
Previn, who is also the adopted daughter of his
ex-partner Mia Farrow. Chomsky said, and this
one is a little weird. If there was a flight,
which I doubt it would have been from Boston
to New York 30 minutes. See, I would remember
whether I flew with Jeffrey Epstein that I
that's strange. But he says I'm unaware of
the principle that requires that I inform you
about an evening spent with a great artist.
Chomsky said. What was known about Epstein was he
had been convicted of a crime and had served the
sentence according to U.S. laws and norms that
yields a clean slate. So listen, I agree that
the responses are a little bit odd. I also have
no reason whatsoever to believe that Chomsky did
anything inappropriate as it relates to the things
that Epstein was accused and previously convicted
of. On the one hand, it would be really easy for
Chomsky to say, Listen, Epstein contacted me to
do seminars for rich people because they
were interested in hearing my perspective.
The thing is, if that's not true, why
would Chomsky make that up and lie if
that's not actually what took place? And so I
understand that Chomsky is responding in what
is sort of, you know, I you could say it's a
strange response, but it also doesn't really
suggests to me that Chomsky did anything wrong.
I don't know that there's too much more to say
about it. And quite frankly, it's not ultra
surprising to me. Listen, if you had said,
Hey, David, you know, knowing that Epstein
met with Clinton, Trump and Dershowitz,
who else would you guess he might have hung out
with? My mind doesn't immediately go to Chomsky,
but I do think it's important to just kind of
generally consider and understand that, um,
it ends up being a small world in a lot of ways.
And so when you say Chomsky knew Epstein, it's
not like a mind blowing shock to me. At the same
time, if there's any evidence at any point that
comes forward that Chomsky did anything wrong,
we'll discuss it. At this point, there is not.